ya han empezado las tareas de rescate en
las zonas más devastadas de la costa
oeste de Florida donde el huracán Ian
azotó con fuerza dejando un paisaje
catastrófico un ejemplo ya lo ven aquí a
mis espaldas estos botes que fueron
literalmente arrastrados por la fuerte
marejada ciclónica y las grandes
inundaciones que se registraron en este
lugar pero hay mucha más devastación
muchísimas casas habrían desaparecido
completamente por la furia de los
vientos el acceso a los lugares más
afectados es muy restringido y solo
pueden entrar ahí el personal de de
emergencia todo apunta a que el saldo de
daños personales puede ser elevado ese
tema que haya un gran número de víctimas
mortales porque se cree que muchos de
los que habrían quedado atrapados en el
agua habrían hecho caso omiso a las
autoridades que advirtieron de la
peligrosidad del huracán e insistieron
hasta la misma mañana del miércoles
cuando faltaban pocas horas para la
llegada de Ian de la necesidad de
evacuar especialmente aquellas personas
que estaban cerca
recibieron la advertencia unos tres
millones de personas al mismo tiempo los
vecinos afectados han empezado a
regresar a sus casas pero muchos de
ellos se han encontrado sin nada solo un
cúmulo de cristales hierros muebles que
salieron volando y muchísimos escombros
saben que el proceso de recuperación de
la zona declarada zona de desastre va a
ser muy largo y no va a ser cuestión de
pocas semanas o incluso pocos meses